foreign
[Music]
therefore spirit is self-knowing Spirit
it knows itself that which is object for
it is or its picture thought is the true
absolute content as we saw it expressed
Spirit itself
it is at the same time not merely the
content of self-consciousness and not
merely object for it but it is also
actual spirit
this is because it runs through the
three elements of its nature
the movement through its own phases
constitutes its actuality what moves
itself that is Spirit it is the subject
of the movement and equally the moving
itself or the substance through which
the subject moves the notion of spirit
which had emerged for us as we entered
the sphere of religion that is as the
movement of self-certain spirit which
forgives evil and in so doing abandons
its own simple unitary nature and rigid
unchangeableness or as the movement in
which what is in an absolute antithesis
recognizes itself as the same as its
opposite this recognition bursting forth
as the affirmative between these
extremes this notion is intuitively
apprehended by the religious
Consciousness to which the absolute
being is revealed and which overcomes
the difference between itself and what
it intuitively apprehends
just as it is subject so also it is
substance and hence it is itself Spirit
just because and insofar as it is this
movement
paragraph
786 is the penultimate paragraph in the
penultimate portion of hegel's
phenomenology that means it's the second
to last paragraph in the second to last
portion of the entire work we've got one
more gigantic very packed paragraph yet
to go to finish out the entire religion
section and then move on to Absolute
knowing which concludes the work and so
you know we're getting to the end of
religion itself we should have a solid
conception of what all this religion
stuff was supposed to be about and and
where we're going next and paragraph 786
does not disappoint because there's a
lot of stuff going on in this
seemingly you know short paragraph
there's a lot that's packed in there and
in multiple ways so let me signal one of
these ways right off the bat you know if
you've been watching this series you
know that every once in a while I get on
Miller's case the translator of the
edition of the phenomenology in English
that we're using right now because
occasionally the choices that he's made
as a translator could be slightly
misleading and this paragraph
unfortunately
is quite full of those sorts of
occasions so I'm gonna have to point
those out as we go through none of them
are damning you know it's not as if
Miller is
mistranslating something as it's
opposite or is something completely
unrelated but you could get a couple
mistakes taken impression so that that's
topic one topic two is that you know
we're moving towards the end of this
work religion for Hegel is something
that is incredibly important Spirit
takes place through it and religion is
sort of like
philosophy I won't even say light but
philosophy
through representational for gestelta
the structures terms comportments it's
not yet philosophy it's not yet absolute
knowing but it's getting pretty close
and so what's happening here in this
paragraph is
um you know the accumulation of all
these things that we've gone through
before
and getting us there you could say
metaphysically and morally in terms of
revealing what religion was supposed to
be about then the third main thing is
that
we can say that there's considerable
um backward reference or Illusions to
what's been going on within the work as
a whole we saw just in the previous
paragraph there was a reference
to the unhappy Consciousness this
important section of the Consciousness
or self-consciousness section which then
leads into the entire massive reason
portion of the work and we shouldn't
leave that behind because that's still
lingering in the background this idea of
God God itself God himself being dead
and the meaning of this death is coming
through into this from the previous
paragraph but there's also a reference
in here a very interesting and kind of
enigmatic reference to what was going on
in the beginning of this religion
section right he says the notion of
spirit which had emerged for us as we
entered the sphere of religion and as
it's going to turn out
that's not exactly what's going on the
way he's describing it as we move into
the beginning of the religion section
some of that's actually
seemingly reverberating into it from the
previous developments in the spirit
section so again we got a lot going on
here a lot to unpack and there is some
really interesting Advance being made
here in this short paragraph
so he says he begins it by saying in
this way therefore also right
spirit
is
self knowing
Spirits now
he actually says that spirit is Zeke
zelps visender so it's not that it's
self-knowing Spirit it is that this is
what spirit
is uh zigzett
um
so not just Zeke wysander but Zeke zelps
knowing itself knowing what it is right
this is an achievement that has been
attained and we're going to see this
same zelps uh formulation showing up a
little bit later in the paragraph when
we've got this locution Dirk Zeke zelps
tinderk so we'll come back to that in a
moment and what does this mean he he
tells us
um now here's Miller's translation it
knows itself that which is object for it
is or its picture thought is the true
absolute content right so
now interestingly in the punctuation in
the German text
um
the semicolon is placed in a somewhat
different spot right
um it knows itself
that which is object for it it knows
itself that and vice Zeke Das something
being the case
and I kind of Wonder here if
maybe we shouldn't choose to translate
the Zeke here in a kind of reflexive way
turning this into it knows not itself it
knows
for itself
as Vice Zeke it knows to itself for
itself
it knows in a more thorough way that and
then we've got these two things
so what is object
giganstund for it right what is opposed
to it what is is standing in front of it
for it is has being it exists right so
it knows itself that the the object is
then more importantly
it's picture thought for Stella
is the true toy right
Vara
absolute
content in halt
so it's the forest along the picture
thought the representation the
imagination the thing that's shared
among the community The Narrative of you
know what we just had in the previous
paragraph the Incarnate God man dying
you know the meaning of that death with
you know the scope of it within the
community all of that stuff that we've
had in the previous paragraphs the you
know overcoming of evil as a result all
of this is true Vara absolute content
it's not absolute being it's not
absolute knowledge it's absolute content
content that has to have a form but
insofar as its content it's true and
it's absolute now this is something
rather extraordinary for Hegel to be
saying about representation or picture
thought for Stellar right but it figures
into what we just saw in the previous
paragraph where it's not as if picture
thought has been radically thrown away
this isn't some sort of let's get away
from images and words mysticism man no
it's not that's not what's going on at
all and we should be very careful given
that hegel's using terminology that can
be translated as intuitive on xiaolong
right
um not to lapse into some sort of new
agey uh everything goes kind of
mysticism because that is at antipodes
of what Hegel is actually
charting out for us hegel's not a fan of
that that sort of thing so this is all
very interesting right and this is
leading us to realize as he says
that
um it expressed yet for stellen right it
expressed Spirit itself
it is at the same time he says not
merely the content of self-consciousness
I mean that's already pretty good right
forestelling is the the content of
self-consciousness not merely object for
it
but it is also
actual vehicle
spirit
so
for stellen representation is not being
uh simply thrown away like a ladder that
you climb up or anything like that it's
being you know of gobus it's being
brought in it's being sublated it's
being transcended it's being superseded
right into absolute actual spirits and
Hegel goes on then and he says something
that's a little bit enigmatic when we
look at the text itself right he says
this is because it runs through the
three elements of its nature now runs
through Dirk loifen right okay so it
runs through these three elementa of its
nature and he says the uh the movement
through its own phases
constitutes its actuality now there is
no through its phases in the German
instead what we actually have is
something quite interesting
Dirk Zeke zep's hinder right so we've
got this dirt through
um
arising twice in this location and we've
got the zig zelps of spirit Zig zop's
visitor right already being hearkened
back to I mean so we've got through and
then through to the other side or
through on its way right through its
phases that's kind of an interpolation I
would say there and then constitutes
mock house it's actuality it's vehicle
okay the the vehicle kite of the
vehicles uh geisters right so
what are these three elements uh here we
gotta do a little bit of
reconstructive work I would say because
Hegel doesn't say well the first is the
second is the third is and Miller is
actually going to add an extra term in
there so the first thing that he says
what moves itself right uh
you know is it's it's air he doesn't say
um what moves itself that is spirits
he says what moves itself that it is it
so is it Spirit yeah I mean every all
this stuff is spirit and it's kind of
trivial sense is he signifying Spirit at
that point no but he's going to be
bringing it in a little bit later so
we've got the first element what moves
itself right and what does move itself
well you know all sorts of things that
aren't dead
living beings
thought
our relationships history pick whatever
you want right and then we get the
second element
it is the subject
of the movement right he says it is the
subject of the movement and is equally
here's the third the moving itself
that's the vegan zelps
so
the substance he says through which the
subject moves so we've got
what moves itself the subject of the
movement now what what does it mean to
be the subject of the movement okay so
things do move themselves but are they
subjects of that movement or are they
merely acted upon subject as I mentioned
in in previous videos implies a certain
kind of agency and at least in the case
of human beings a teleology you could
say an orientation towards something and
it also involves because we're talking
about self-consciousness is here an
awareness of their own lack and relation
to other self-consciousnesses and what
it is that they desire on air cannon
recognition there's a whole bunch of
things going on here and then we've got
the moving itself which is the substance
through which the subject moves itself
right so we've got this complicated
analysis of movement or moving but they
going or the Vega in right and it
introduces subject and substance and
then Hegel will talk about the notion of
spirits
right so the concept the begraph of
spirit which had emerged for us as we
enter the sphere of religion Okay so
let's actually backtrack and if you
don't mind a little bit of digression
here and going back to the actual
beginning of the religion section what
do we have being discussed so there's
you know quite a bit of uh bringing
together of hey there were four previous
movements uh Consciousness
self-consciousness reason and spirit and
each of these has gone through an
important transition we see a reference
already in the second paragraph to the
unhappy Consciousness then reason and
then discussion about the ethical world
and what we're getting are all sorts of
shapes of not just Consciousness or
Spirit but but of
you know prefigurations of religion
right
and then we get to the religion of
morality
is in paragraph 676 uh the fact that
absolute being is a positive content is
at last recognized the content is bound
up with the negativity of the
Enlightenment right and then we get the
uh this discussion in 677 the
self-knowing spirit is in religion
immediately its own pure
self-consciousness
and we go on from from this again
talking about different shapes different
gestalten of consciousness of religious
being and then in 678 I I think here and
in the the ones that come after it we
start to get a little bit more meat so
to speak he says that
um spirit's existence is distinct from
its self-consciousness its reality Falls
outside of religion there is indeed one
Spirit of both but its Consciousness
does not Embrace both together and
religion appears as part of existence of
conduct and activity whose other part is
the life lived in the real world and so
really what we have is two different
kinds of vehicles
actuality religion and then the real
world right that religion super and
being super uh yeah
supersedes you could say and so what do
we got here though so we entered the
sphere of religion uh the movement of
self-certain spirit okay I think we've
got that going on here Spirit has become
uh certain of itself in some ways right
he tells us that the Genesis of religion
in general is contained in the movement
of the universal
moments self-consciousness is a very
important
part of that
um
but he also tells us all we've got here
is the notion the the concept the
begrith of religion and we have to
develop it now what does he tell us
going back to 786
so as we enter the sphere of religion
the movement of self-certain spirit
which does what forgives evil
now if you look in these first
paragraphs at the beginning of the
religion section
do you see a discussion of the
Forgiveness of evil
no you will see lots of discussion of
the Forgiveness of evil
throughout the religion section but not
so much at the beginning but there was
some discussion of this earlier in the
spirit section so what does Hegel
actually
signifying to us here is he saying
that's what was really being uh
addressed discussed I just didn't call
it as such that's one possible read of
this but let's see where he's going here
what happens when it forgives evil it
abandons its own simple unitary nature
and rigid unchangeableness
all right so it is uh developing it's
becoming more complex in relation to us
us human beings who have religion who
comport ourselves religiously who Orient
ourselves to you know what the unhappy
Consciousness called the Beyond to the
God that was now engaged with us and not
just uh in absolute or you know revealed
religion right but already in the other
earlier shapes of religion particularly
in the religion is a work of art section
right and the cult so he goes on and he
tells us
uh as the movement in which what is in
an absolute antithesis okay so religious
consciousness
is realizing this notion of spirit how
so uh through the movement itself
certain Spirit forgiving evil great but
what else do we have a movement
which is uh an absolute antithesis in
which what is in an absolute antithesis
recognizes now recognizes ekant or Kents
rather right so knows itself recognizes
works for that this is not on air Canon
right this is air cannon so it's not
quite the same thing as like recognition
of the capital r that Spirit or us is
Desiring right but there is a
recognition here
um the what is in an absolute antithesis
recognizes itself as the same as its
opposite all right so what do we have
here absolute antithesis absolute and
gagan gazetsta
and it's Das and Kagan Gazette
so that's singular that's kind of
interesting isn't it uh it's one thing
here that is in an absolute antithesis
with itself it recognizes itself
as the same as its opposite now as it's
opposite
not in the German there Zeke alts Das
Elba air Kent right it recognizes itself
right as the same
as having
opposition within it and as being the
same as that opposition
that's a good way to frame it there and
so he says that this recognition bursts
forth as the affirmative and the
affirmative there is just a yeah yes uh
you know it doesn't have to be quite so
uh wordy as affirmative between these
extremes now here is where he says this
notion this concept is intuitively
apprehended okay it's not intuitively
apprehended it is what we have here is
on show it it sees it it grasps it it
you could say intuitively but don't make
an appeal to a faculty of intuition you
know or try to equate conceptual thought
with unshowing uh on or intuition
because that's not what hagel's doing
here it's it Grant it realizes it it
grasps it right uh by the religious
Consciousness to which the absolute
being is revealed open bar right that
and we've been dealing with the at the
revealed religion here
and then it goes which overcomes the
difference between itself and what it
intuitively apprehends again on shown
right so
um the difference between itself what it
what is doing the looking on and what is
looked upon what is being grasped we
have a unity and difference here right
and not a big surprise because hegel's
all about that all the time right when
things aren't being split apart and put
into antithesis with each other now here
he is going to conclude by bringing in
one more really important thing
bringing this paragraph to a close and
getting us ready for the final paragraph
of the religion section
just as it is subject
it is also substance
so okay we've got that already here in
this movement through its phases right
subject and substance
and hence it is itself Spirit just
because and insofar as it is this
movement so we see these three uh
moments or uh elements brought back
together in the the last thing and what
we've got here is something that is
spirits and substance and subject and of
course
self and self-consciousness all coming
together in a Crux and now we're ready
to finish up with the religion section